[موسيقى]
يقول عبد الوهاب المسيري حتى مواعيد ساعات
العمل استوردناها من الغرب دون تفكير او
اجتهاد ويضيف انها ساعات تصلح لبلادهم
ولظروفها اما بالنسبه لبلادنا فيوم العمل
المناسب يمكن ان يبدا بعد صلاه الفجر
وينتهي عند وقت الظهيره على ان يستانف
الناس حياتهم الاجتماعيه بعد العصر
ليناموا بعد صلاه العشاء الى العناوين
امريكا وايران تتبادلان السجناء في الدوحه
وفد حوثي في السعوديه
سفير الامارات بواشنطن يعلن عن الفشل في
تغيير موقف اسرائيل
زلزال المغرب مفتعل يصر اصحاب نظريه
المؤامره
مقتدى الصدر شامتا بضحايا الاعصار ذنب
ليبيا غير مغفور
[موسيقى]
الرباط تنفي وجود اسم ماكرون على جدول
استقبالات الملك
ظهور غريب لسفاح سوريا وجنرال الموتى
الروسي في مسجد بالجزائر
رئيس وزراء تونس يعلن ان الرئيس قيس سعيد
لا شبيه له
نجاه سائح كويتي من القتل في تركيا التي
نهزت خسائرها خمسه مليارات دولار
زفه الكوارع لشيخ الفراخ عمرو خالد في
القاهره
[موسيقى]
مرحبا يقول المثل العربي اذا كان جارك
بخير فانت بخير ويقول المثل الفارسي رويدا
رويدا يتحول الصوف الى سجاده هل ان
الاشارات الايجابيه الملتقطه على خط واشنط
طهران مرورا بالدوحه ستشكل خيوطا اوليه
لعباءه استقرار طال انتظارها وتعثر نسجها
مرارا وهل ان اتمام صفقه تبادل السجناء
بين واشنطن وطهران ستعطي الامل بالافراز
عن استحقاقات متعثره في بيروت ودمشق
وبغداد تنعكس بخطوات من شانها ان تسهم في
حلحله الاوضاع في المنطقه التي تكفيها
كوارث الطبيعه ونقص التنبيه وارتفاع
معدلات الفقر والفوضى والفساد هذا وقال
رئيس الوزراء الوزير الخارجيه القطري
الشيخ محمد بن عبد الرحمن ال ثاني انه
يامل ان يمهد الاتفاق الامريكي الايراني
بشان تبادل السجناء لمزيد من التفاهمات
اضاف في منشور على منصه اكس انه يتوجه
بالشكر لطرفي الاتفاق قطر الذين ساهموا في
انجاحه لا سيما سلطنه عمان وفي طهران
استقبال اسطوري لنادي النصر السعودي ونجمه
رونالدو فما تفعله الرياضه تعجز عنه
احيانا السياسه والاقتصاد هي اشياء لا
تشترى بهذه الكلمات عبر نادي النصر عن
فخره بفريقه والحاله التي اوجدها في طهران
فور وصول بعثه النادي السعودي الى ايران
اليوم احبب حبيبك هونا ما عسى ان يكون
بغيضك يوما ما وابغض بغيضك هونا ما عسى ان
يكون حبيبك يوما ما وفد حوثي سياسي في
الرياض لاول مره يقترب اليمن اكثر من اي
وقت مضى من الحل السياسي المنشود المنهي
لازمه صنفت انها ضمن الاكثر معاناه
التفاؤل قادم من زياره هي الاولى منذ ان
دخل اليمن دائره الازمات المملكه تستضيف
وفدا حوثيا لاستكمال المباحثات التي بدات
على وقع زياره سفير المملكه لدى اليمن
محمد ال جابر الى صنعاء في ابريل الماضي
اعرب السفير الاماراتي لدى واشنطن يوسف
العتيبه عن دهشته لسرعه التقبل والتبادل
الثقافي والس بين الاماراتيين
والاسرائيليين السفير يوسف العتيبه يقول
لقد فشلنا في التاثير على اسرائيل لوقف
بناء المستوطنات والتقدم بشان حل الدولتين
والمسؤوليه الان يضيف تقع على عاتق ما
وصفها بالدول المستقبليه
[موسيقى]
باحث مصري في علوم ما وراء الطبيعه هكذا
يصف نفسه كاد ان يحلف بالطلاق على ان
زلازل المغرب وتركيا وسوريا مفتعله
وبالدلائل يقول دون ان يقدمها وكل حاجه
بتحصل بامر ربنا سبحانه وتعالى ولكن هناك
زلازل طبيعيه دي بتحصل عادي فعل الطبيعه
وفي هناك زلازل اخرى بتحصل نتيجه تدخلات
بشريه ابرز مثالين عندنا ما حدث في سوريا
وما حدث في المغرب لكن مثلا كان في زلزال
في اندونيسيا يعتقد اول امبارح بيتهيا لي
لما نيجي نشوفه لانه حصل على بعد 150 كيلو
متر من سطح البحر
اما الزلازل المفروض ان هي مصطنعه بتحصل
10 15 25 كيلو متر من سطح البحر وده برده
يؤكد ان هذا المصطنعه مش زلازل طبيعيه
نظريه وافتعال الزلازل عبر مشروع هارب
الامريكي يخرجها اصحابها عند كل هزه او
زلزال كما يخرج الساحر ارنبه من القبعه
هو برنامج سري لابحاث الشفق القطبي يتبع
لسلاح الجو الامريكي ومهمته دراسه كيفيه
زياده كثافه الغاز والتي تحول بعد اغلاقه
عام 2015 الى جامعه الاسكا لكنه ما زال
متهما باحداث الزلازل استاذ الزلازل
بالمعهد القومي المصري صلاح الحديدي يطمئن
المصريين الزلازل بتاعتنا على قدنا فما
تقلقوش في سوريا وتركيا وفي المغرب مباني
هشه قديمه ما فيش فيها المعايير مشاكل
البناء ليست موجوده اساسا في مصر يؤكد
خالد الجندي الذي ظهر في احدى حلقات
برنامجه الديني بدور مهندس اللي حصل
حوالين مننا ده يخلينا نرفع القبعه
احتراما وانحناء واقرارا اقرارا بانه هذا
الرجل اللي عمله في الوقت الق ياسي ده كان
شيء ضروري كنا محتاجينه للغايه وما زلنا
محتاجين للمزيد ولسه الرحله ما انتهتش ده
في قرى في دول اخرى ابيدت
اتمسحت بسبب عدم الاشتراطات البناء فيما
عملياته البحث والتنقيب جاريه عن ضحايا
ومصابي اعصار ليبيا فاجا مقتدى الصدر
الامه بما اعتبر شماته فاضحه منه بضحايا
ليبيا واهلها بحجه ان معمر القذافي الذي
خلعه شعبه اخفى السيد موسى الصدر قبل
عشرات الاعوام فيقول مقتدى الكوارث
الطبيعيه غضب سماوي وذنب ليبيا غير مغفور
حمى الله العراق وشعبه مجله شلي ابدل
الفرنسيه سيئه السمعه والسريره سمتت
بضحايا زلزال تركيا قبل شهور واليوم رجل
الدين مقتدى الصدر يتفوق على شارليه ابدوب
باصوات كما علق ليبيون في وقت تعاني فيه
ليبيا من اكبر انسانيه تشهدها منذ عشرات
السنوات تصريح غريب لزعيم التيار الصدري
مقتدى الصدر بشان اعصار دانييل في ليبيا
يثير حاله من الجدل الصدر ذكر ضمن عده
تصريحات عن الكوارث الطبيعيه ان ذنب ليبيا
غير مغفور لعدم كشفها ما حل بموسى الصدر
بعد زيارته لليبيا واختفائه هناك عام
1978 المعمم العراقي شهيد العتابي ينفي
صفه التشيع عن اي عراقي ويعتبر نفسه وشيعه
العراق محبين وموالين لاهل البيت عليهم
السلام لكنهم لا يحملون صفاتهم يقول ايش
قد عندنا الشيعه بالطبقه السياسيه تؤمن
بيهم كشيعه
شيعه شنو يعني شيعه حقيقيين لو شيعه وقبل
واحد اثنين ثلاثه حقيقي ولا واحد بالعراق
ولا واحد بالعراق بالعراق ولا واحد انت مو
شيعي لا انا موالي ومحب الشيعه لهم صفات
اهل ورعن واجتهاد صوامون الليل قوامون
النهار لا يقربون لا يقربون المحرمات ابدا
اقرب على صفاتهم وصفاتهم وشوفوا الشيعه
رئيس مجلس النواب اللي بي عقيل صالح
يتجاوز سلوكيات رجال الدوله وغلبه القانون
وحتى ادبيات العشائر فيغضب الليبيين
بمطالبتهم بعدم انتقاد المسؤولين الذين لم
يتخذوا اجراءات الوقايه اللازمه قبل
الكارثه سبقت مقادير الله وحكمه فرح فؤادك
من لعله من لو قدر الله ولا شاء فعل ما
نقولوش لو ان كذا وفعلنا كذا وعملنا كذا
من قال الام دنيا ظلم الام فالام دنيا
واخره وقلب فوق القلوب حيين انتم اي هل
الجميع على قيد الحياه ام من تحت الانقاض
بدرنا تسال ابنها فور سماعها صوته يناديها
[موسيقى]
الكلب ايثار ينقذ سبعه وعشرين شخصا من تحت
انقاض درنا بليبيا يسر الله للشعوب
اليتيمه كلابا تحميها هذا هو العريف ابار
من قسم النجده بنغازي يتوسط مجموعه من
رجال الانقاذ بعدما ساعدهم في الوصول الى
27 يناج وانتشالهم من تحت الانقاذ بالقرب
من مسجد الصحابه في الاعلام بالفرنسيه
وليس في صحف عربيه يسخرون من ايمانيول
ماكرون الذي يلح على المغرب قبول مساعده
فرنسا عقب الزلزال والمغرب لا يريد ميرسي
اوروبا نشوفكم بالافراح
[موسيقى]
مع ان المثل الفرنسي يقول لا تضيع وقتك مع
من ليس جاهزا لقضائه معك يصر الرئيس
الفرنسي
على عقد اجتماع مع ملك المغرب محمد السادس
ولو في مخيلته يضرب موعدا من جانب واحد
وتعلن وزيره خارجيته عن جدول زيارته
للرباط والرباط لا علم لها وليست جاهزه
الان لاستقباله بصراحه مشغوله تعليق مغربي
لافاد مصدر حكومي رسمي مغربي بان زياره
الرئيس الفرنسي امانويل ماكرون للمغرب
ليست مدرجه في جدول الاعمال ولا مبرمجه
وكانت وزيره الخارجيه الفرنسيه كاثرين
كولونا قد اعلنت في حديث لاحدى القنوات
الاخباريه عن برمجه زياره لرئيس ماكرون
الى المغرب بدعوه من صاحب الجلاله الملك
محمد السادس وعبر المصدر الحكومي الرسمي
ذاته عن استغرابه لكون السيده كولون اتخذت
هذه المبادره وحاضيه الجانب ومنحت لنفسها
حريه اصدار اعلان غير متشور بشانه بخصوص
استحقاق ثنائي هامه
[موسيقى]
في الديمقراطيه يتساوى العالم والجاهل
الصالح والطالح الخير والسرير اما في
الحرب
فاماؤها هم من يحددون مصائر العباد
والبلاد
حمستي يهدد بتقسيم السودان وتشكيل سلطه
عاصمتها الخرطوم في حال تشكيل البرهان
سلطه في بورتسودان يتحدث قائد قوات الدعم
السريع محمد حمدان دوجلو عن مشاورات
لتشكيل سلطه مدنيه في المناطق الخاضعه
لسيطرته ردا كما قال على محاولات عبد
الفتاح البرهان اداره شؤون البلاد من
بورتسودان الاعلام المصري وصفه بالجنرال
المجنون بينما وصفته صحيفه القدس بجزار
سوريا ويصفه الاعلام الروسي تجاوزا بجنرال
يوم القيامه
قائد القوات الجويه الروسيه السابق الذي
اقيل من منصبه بعد انقلاب فاجنر الاخير
ظهر فجاه في الجزائر وتحديدا في احد
مساجدها مع امام المسجد
وامامهما نسخه من المصحف الشريف بالتاكيد
هو لم يذهب لاشهار اسلامه لكن الطرفين
الجزائريه والروسي لم يعلنا عن سبب
الزياره وفدروس رفيع المستوى الى الجامع
الرئيسي القطب عبد الحميد بن بادي كان في
استقبالهم مدير الشؤون الدينيه والاوقاف
وامام الجامع الرئيسي ابو عبد الله زبار
حيث ظهروا مرافق المسجد وابدوا اعجابهم
الجنرال المجنون ظهر في الصور لابس زي غير
عسكري ومن هو واحد من القاده المخضرمين في
الحروب الكثير اللي خاضتها موسكو بدايه من
الاحتجاج السوفيتي لافغانستان ومرورا
بتدخل العسكري في سوريا ووصولا للعمليات
في اوكرانيا ولغايه دلوقتي محدش عارف ايه
سبب الزياره دي ولا الهدف منها ايه اين
كان جنرال الجحيم خلال الفتره الماضيه
ولماذا
ظهر فجاه في توقيت مريب ومكان غريب انا ما
عشان ارسم عشان اخطط انا شغلتي شغله مزاجي
يا استاذ مش لعبه قال
رئيس الوزراء التونسي المعين حديثا احمد
الحساني يتبوا بسرعه قياسيه للمركز الاول
على صعيد المسؤولين العرب الذين يتلعثمون
في الخطابات والتصريحات عشان يؤكد ان
النجاح لتونس وصغارنا
كما اعلن ان الرئيس قيس سعيد لا شبيه له
ما ثماش واحد كيفه
الحمد لله
واحنا مع تونس
تونس
بلاد
منوره انا انا
شدد الرئيس التونسي قيس سعيد على اهميه
تشجيع القطاع الخاص لمحاربه البطاله واعطى
مثالا عن شركه جديده ناجحه في منطقه زغوان
الشركه تربح كل يوم اربعين دولارا امريكيا
اي ما يعادل 140 دينارا تونسيا تقضي على
البطاله تمام
اول وحده
في المده الاخرى
لما تكون في ولايه زهوان
[موسيقى]
العنصريه ضد العرب كلفت تركيا هذا الصيف
وحتى الان فقط خمسه مليارات دولار هذا ليس
كلامنا بل كلام المستشار الرئاسي التركي
السابق ياسين قطاعي فهل يدرك العنصريون
المدعومون من بعض احزاب المعارضه
العلمانيه المتطرفه انهم بكراهيتهم للعرب
واحيانا للمسلمين انما يقطعون غصن الشجره
الذي يتكئون عليه
اوروبا لا تريدكم بينما العرب يحبونكم لكن
ليس اكثر من انفسهم انتبهوا وبحسب صحيفه
تركيا المحسوبه على حزب العداله والتنميه
الحاكم فان الممارسات العنصريه تجاه العرب
والاجانب بشكل عام دفعت بكبار رؤوس
الاموال العربيه لنقل تجارتهم
واستثماراتهم من البلاد القط السلطات
التركيه القبض على مجرم كذا يتسبب بمقتل
السائح الكويتي محمد رزيق الذي كان يزور
مع اسرته مدينه طرابزون والتي صارت ضرب
زون كما يبدو محمد قدم روايته وقال ان
المشكله بدات مع عاملين سوريين في المقهى
الذي رفض اصطحاب زوارهم ماكولات من خارجها
مدير المطعم السوري قال لاحقا للاعلام
المحلي ان السائح الكويتيه شتمهم وبصق
عليهم لكن دون ان يبرز فيديوهات كتلك التي
اظهرت الاعتداء الصارخ على المواطن
الكويتي
[موسيقى]
ضربه
في الامام اللي خلالها انكسرت اسناني
الاماميه
وجتني ضربه في الخلف باله حاده هي اللي
خلتني يعني طحت اغمى علي الموضوع كبر
بالكويت لا سيما وان الاعتداءات
والمضايقات تكررت في تركيا سفاره الكويت
في انقره استنفرت لمتابعه القضيه ووزير
الخارجيه الكويتي اتصل بمواطنه المعتاد
عليه للاطمئنان الى وضعه وقالت الخارجيه
في بيان لها ان الوزيره اكد ان السلطات
المحليه التركيه تتخذ حاليا الاجراءات
اللازمه بحق المعتدي الرئيس التركي رجب
طيب اردوغان كان قد اكد ان الاجراءات
القانونيه
ستعاقب المعتدين العنصريين فهل تتداركوا
سلطات انقر الامر بسرعه قبل ان تصبح تركيا
اخر وجهات العرب السياحيه لا يمكننا
اطلاقا السماح بتجذر الالاعيب الخبيثه
التي تتسبب بتخريب نسيج الاجتماعي من
استفزازات التنظيمات الارهابيه وبعض
السياسيين وحتى سموم العنصريه وكراهيه
الاجانب سنتخذ جميع التدابير اللازمه ضد
الخارجين عن القانون
في المتفرقات وزع الاعلام المصري الرسمي
بيانا يعلن فيه عن تخريج القوات المسلحه
الدفعه الاولى من الائمه المرشحين للعمل
بوزاره الاوقاف وذلك بعد اتمام دورتهم
التدريبيه بالكليه نشرت شبكه ام بي سي
التلفزيونيه على قنواتها في وسائل التواصل
الاجتماعي مقطع فيديو يظهر فيه رئيس هيئه
الترفيه السعودي
المستشار التركي ال الشيخ يخاطب المذيعه
المصري العامل في ام بي سي عمر اديب مشيدا
بعمله ومؤكدا ان عمرو هو صناعه سعوديه امر
اديب انت مجتهد
مذيع متفوق رائع ناجح شاطر
لكن جزء من نجاحك وجزء من تاريخك صناعه
سعوديه اغلب عمري بشتغل في محطه سعوديه كم
اشتغلت
15 سنه 14 سنه وهي البدايات صح واللي عرفت
الناس فيك بعدها
فتره جاد نتيجه بيع اوربت نتيجه الاحداث
السياسيه في مصر وبعدين الان انت داخل
السنه الخامسه بالضبط فانت انت صناعه جزء
من الصناعه السعوديه يا عمرو
لنفتخر فيها ونعتز فيها ونحبها يعني وانا
لي الفخر كمان ان انا بشتغل يعني
وبالتاكيد وبالتاكيد راح تغطي اشياء تهمنا
ليش متغطي اشياء انت اول شيء تشتغل في
مؤسسه ايش سعوديه فعشان كده انت بتغطي
بتغطي هذا الموضوع اخيرا بعد لقب شيخ
الفراخ الذي ناله مع تمثيله دعايه تجاريه
لماركه دجاج اعتذر لاحقا عن تقديمها شيخ
الكوارع لقب جديد يكتسبه الداعيه المصريه
عمرو خالد بعد ظهوره في مطعم فخم يقدم
وجبه يقال لها الكوارع وفريق المطعم يحتفل
بعمر افندي ويقيم له زفه الكوارع
علما ان من حقه ان ياكل مثل غيره بس انتم
ناطرين على شغله
دكتور عمرو خالد
[موسيقى]
عشان نجمنا اللامع هنعمل شوكه
ختاما قالوا عن البحر انه حافظ الاسرار
والذكريات لكنهم لم يقولوا انه محطم
القلوب وقبله الدموع شاب ليبي يسعى بين
صخرتين في ناحيه من شاطئ مدينه درنه يحاكي
الامواج ببدها وجزرها مترقبا عوده عائلته
معها ولو جثامين يكرمها بدفنها بعد ميته
الغرق التي بشر الرسول محمد صلى الله عليه
وسلم اصحابها فقال الشهداء خمسه المطعون
والمطون والغريق وصاحب الهدم والشهيد في
سبيل الله
الى اللقاء ساجد اهلك
وقاعد ليه ساعتين رغم اني مقربتش منه من
بعيد لكن قاعد لي ساعتين واقف في نفس
المكان ويرجع يدور ويرجع في نفس المكان
فنسال الله ان يغفر لهم ويرحمهم كانوا
مفقودين ان شاء الله ربي يلاقي بهم في اي
حد يشوف الفيديو يدعي له نسال الله
السلامه وان شاء الله ربك يفرج على الجميع
اخ اخ يا بحر
شو بشكي
لك وين الغوالي وينه
وين
الغوالي ويل يا بحر
[موسيقى]
انت اللي بعيني
وبينوا
النيابه
يا بحر ارحمني ورجعني ليمون
يا من تيم يا بحر
[موسيقى]